well more protests breaking out across
california over the weekend in defiance
of governor gavin newsom's 10 p.m
covet curfew order that went into effect
for most counties saturday night
our next guest is a california sheriff
who says she won't be enforcing it
fresno county sheriff margaret mims
joins us now and sheriff
so good of you to join us we appreciate
it very much why did you decide
not to enforce the curfew
well this is consistent with the actions
or non-actions we've taken since this
the beginning
i don't believe this is a law
enforcement issue we are so busy
enforcing and keeping our citizens safe
by
arresting robbers and child molesters
and
home burglars that making criminals out
of normally law abiding citizens doesn't
make sense
yeah i know we have talked about the
crime stats in california they have gone
way up
i know you're not going to criticize
some of your colleagues but we should
point out that the san diego
county sheriff says that he will enforce
the curfew
sheriff los angeles county sheriff
villanueva said the following so he's
kind of
going to enforce it he said this we have
a lot of options and pretty much on the
voluntary compliance side
we get most of our success if we start
scratching paper mean writing tickets
there's consequences that need to follow
from that
and we don't want to get to that point
so again not to criticize your
colleagues but what do you think of the
various strategies being implemented
across the state
well you i trust californians and most
are doing the right thing
when it makes common sense so for
instance
when when the governor talks about this
curfew between 10 at night till 5 in the
morning
it's a head scratcher is this virus so
smart that it's not going to
infect people if they're not in their
homes by 9 59
we all make our own decisions about
what's best for our communities
and in fact our local district attorney
has said she's not going to file charges
or even prosecute
if they're brought to her so it it we're
very consistent in our county with
our joint efforts in really keeping our
citizens safe
and trusting our people to do the right
thing
you talk about you know is the virus
smart enough that it doesn't you know
attack people between ten o'clock and
six o'clock in the morning
you know a lot of people a lot of
businesses we talk to especially
restaurants
and gymnasiums and these hair salons
that seem to be low-hanging fruit
los angeles county is now shutting down
outdoor dining again
this week what do you make of these
various things when you talk to the
scientists now sheriff and they say you
know we really do not know
where the vast majority of these
infections where people are catching
these
and yet some of the same businesses some
of the same
curfews are targeting people again and
again and again your thoughts on that
well our businesses many of them are not
going to survive this when you take a
look at big box stores
and their profits and how they've gone
up during this pandemic
and we're losing our local businesses
and that means local jobs
it's it's a again i'll call it a head
scratcher where i believe
people will voluntarily comply when
things make sense to them
however this local curfew between those
hours it doesn't make sense
and again we need to really put our
trust in people to do the right thing
and most of our local communities are
you hardly go anywhere where you don't
see people
wearing a mask these days and i'm just
encouraging our local communities
absolutely when you're in a crowd when
you're being exposed to other people
wear a mask wash your hands
and social distance but some of these
restrictions
and government control procedures are
just not making sense to me
yeah and you've mentioned head scratcher
a couple of times the man who's in
charge of the head scratchers you talk
about is the governor of california
gavin newsom who said this watch
daily cases though in the state of
california have doubled
just in the last 10 days this is simply
the fastest increase
california has seen since the beginning
of this
pandemic so it's certainly getting worse
sheriff is there a point in this where
you think maybe
you might take the governor's side on
some of these different
crackdowns well again
when something makes sense and they have
the science and the data to back it up
uh that's something to be considered
absolutely
uh but when it doesn't make sense it's
you know common sense is
is really what people will believe and
so far i haven't seen much of that
yeah sheriff margaret mims thank you
ma'am appreciate it
thank you happy thanksgiving